good evening everyone my name is Greg
sterling I'm the Dean of Yale Divinity
School just up the street and a member
of the Terry committee and on behalf of
the committee it is the distinct
pleasure to welcome you to the second of
the Terry lectures in 2018 and as was
true after the first lecture there will
be a Q&A period I will invite you if you
would when you have a question to come
up to the mic and introduce yourself
briefly and pose your question and
following the lectureship not like most
years we actually have another reception
so you'll have a chance to visit with
one another following the lecture
tonight introducing Tom Lovejoy presents
an interesting dilemma on the one hand
he's such an important figure that he
deserves a full introduction on the
other hand you didn't come here to hear
about Tom Lovejoy you came here to hear
Tom Lovejoy so allow me to compromise by
offering some select pieces of
information that will contextualize the
lecture known as The Godfather of
biodiversity how else would a Divinity
School Dean introduce him his career
choice was made very early in life in
high school when he worked for the
trevor zoo while attending Millbrook
school this is the only accredited zoo
on a high school campus in the United
States I don't know how many species
they had when you were a student there
but today they have more than 80 species
and a hundred and eighty exotic and
indigenous animals nine of whom are on
the endangered list and that experience
of working with different species
captivated his mind he came to Yale
where he studied with g evelyn
hutchinson the founder of modern ecology
dillan Ripley an ornithologist and the
former director of the Peabody and
Philip Humphrey who introduced him to
the Amazon the region of his life's work
he is unlimited and maybe I should even
say unlimite ball by a single sphere of
work scientist government advisor and
environmentalist as a scientist he is
most famous for his concept or
development of the concept of
biodiversity a term that he coined in a
report to President Carter in 1980 in a
separate publication of the same year he
wrote hundreds of thousands of species
will perish and this reduction of 10 to
20 percent of the world's biota will
occur in about half a human lifespan
this reduction of the biological
diversity of the planet is the most
basic issue of our time and if you were
here last Thursday you know that that
issue has only become even more urgent
he has done however more than to point
out and analyze the crisis that we face
he's offered practical solutions some of
which have garnered a great deal of
attention the most famous of which was
his debt for nature swaps in which he
proposed groups of wealthy
conservationists purchased the national
debt of underdeveloped countries and
then used the funds from that debt that
was purchased to purchase tracts of
lands that would be environmentally
protected he has he is an example of a
scientist who not only does research but
is made policy suggestions that have
captured a good deal of attention now I
haven't mentioned his academic
appointment at George Mason his 10 plus
books his service to three presidents of
the United States
his work at the Smithsonian or the
United Nations Foundation his role with
the famous series nature his five or
more international awards when I say
international I mean truly international
or his the fact that he's a Wilbur cross
recipient from this university as one of
our own but there's one award that I
need to mention in 2004 Ronald Zuniga
discovered a new species of wasps in
Costa Rica the National Biodiversity
Institute named it poly syrtis love
Louie in honor of our speaker in this
second of three Terry lectures for the
year he will address the issue of Frank
Benteen creation I am assuming that just
as he provided a fresh look at
biodiversity in the first lecture he
will offer us insights into the
fragmentation of habitats a concept that
he has formally addressed since 1978 and
that poses one of the greatest
challenges to dot biodiversity and like
you I am ready and anxious to hear him
professor love drug
[Applause]
so I probably should explain where the
phrase the Godfather biodiversity came
from it's when somebody interests you
introduced me as the father of
biological diversity and I said no
that's biologically impossible right so
so last week we explored essentially the
state of biodiversity and how it relates
to the value systems of the great
religions of the planet and basically
began to ask the question how do we
embed human aspiration in nature what I
want to do this evening is look at one
particular aspect of it the way we
fragment habitats which we do almost
anywhere humans occur in the planet but
also some first thoughts about how do we
stitch it back together again
how can we begin the whole exercise of
regaining the emerald planet a big part
of which will be in Thursday's talk so
this is a sequence of forest cover from
about 1945 I remember right in the
Atlantic forests of Brazil up until
looks like 1974 this is a typical
pattern that occurs wherever people are
occupying landscapes natural habitat is
removed and almost always a consequence
of that is that a fair amount of that
a chat ends up as fragments and here you
can see it in a famous figure from the
both the paper in the book McArthur and
Wilson's Island biogeography we're
looking at a chance ship in Wisconsin
from 1831 on the upper upper left down
through 1950 on the lower right and
interestingly enough habitat
fragmentation simply was not considered
a serious conservation issue and that's
because most of the consequences of
fragmentation play out over time and so
people really don't get to see sort of
the entire consequence of habitat
fragmentation and it was only with the
publication of Island biogeography that
people began to think about it well
these are three statistics that will
tell you how widespread forest
fragmentation is that 70% of remaining
forest eyes within one kilometer of the
forest edge half within 500 meters and
much of the fragments are really small
around ten hectares so it was looking at
the numbers of species on islands that
MacArthur and Wilson began to develop
their perspective on what sets the
number of species on islands it
certainly was very obvious that bigger
islands had more species than smaller
islands as we're looking at here in the
West Indies and you can plot them as you
know proper statistical analyses but
it's the same result bigger islands have
more species in smaller islands but
looking at all of that it was really
hard to sort of puzzle out what was
going on it's when you looked at the
difference between continental Islands
let's get we had before I guess we're
gonna see this twice so when you look at
continental islands ones that originally
were connected to a mainland like
Trinidad to South America and compare
them through a similar sized island
which has never been connected to a big
piece of continent you find that the
Continental islands have a smaller
number of species than or a greater
number of species and oceanic islands
the ones that have always been separate
and then if you look at the comparable
piece of mainland to a continental
Island you see that the continental
island has fewer species than the
equivalent piece of habitat on the
mainland so then those observations led
to this consideration that actually the
number of species you may find on an
island is actually dynamic that in fact
what's going on is that continental
islands start off so when Trinidad was
isolated essentially with an equivalent
number of species to the equivalent area
on the mainland and it those declined in
number until eventually they approached
something like an oceanic island so that
raised a big conservation question to
what extent can numbers of species on
Islands inform us about what happens to
habitats islands that are left by human
impact
on the environment and so that's the
current version of the famous book which
I first saw when I was actually living
in the Amazon for my PhD thesis and this
basically was the proposition that the
number of species you found on a
particular Island was a consequence of
this graph of an equilibrium between the
immigration of new species and species
extinction on the particular islands and
finally getting a little bit beyond
theory there were some islands where
there actually were some data and
foremost amongst those was barro
Colorado Island in the Panama Canal Zone
created in the nineteen teens or
thereabouts for the Panama Canal studied
by ornithologists over the decades since
then and it was very clear that in the
1920s there are 208 species of birds on
Barrow Colorado which had declined by
1972 a smaller number and in this
analysis done by Ed Willis he determined
that 45 of his species that went extinct
did so because barro Colorado Island was
not big enough to support them over time
so as one begins to think about the
implications for conservation and
National Park design and the rest you
can see that this kind of thinking in
the early 1970s really began to get
everybody's attention and there are
different data sets this is looking at
chaparral habitats which are sort of
islands and canyons in San Diego County
and if you look at them over time
as they become isolated they actually
decline in the number of species and
then you could look at forest forest
sort of almost wood Lots in South Paulo
state and imagine how the current bird
diversity got there from some unknown
original bird diversity and similarly
how the abundance of some of these
species actually declined over time but
nobody really knew what the original
state of all those places were except
for barrel Colorado and there was a
there was a heated debate like you can
only have in academia when there's no
direct data I mean it was a white-hot
debate it's called what's better a
single large protected area or several
small ones
and it was it was really incandescent
one poll of that controversy with Daniel
sim Burrell off who in fact was quite
correct in his assertion that Island
biogeography was actually neutral in in
terms of one large versus several small
but that was Island biogeography Theory
as opposed to the way communities are
put together and they're just simply not
put together randomly I was working for
the World Wildlife Fund advancing
projects to the board for approval and I
realized that until we understood what
habitat fragmentation actually does that
we really basically didn't know whether
any of those projects would be
successful in the end so so I worried
that topic everybody knew I was worrying
that topic like a dog worries a bone
and the Monday before Christmas in 1976
I went over to a meeting at the National
Science Foundation at the invitation of
my good friend Fran James John Brooks
formerly from Yale was there and Dan
several off was there and that's where
for whatever reason I came out with I
wonder if you could persuade the
Brazilians to arrange the 50% of forest
which they've been required be left
intact in any project in the Amazon and
when if you could persuade them to
rewrite arranged the 50% to have a giant
experiment and so that was the origin of
something I've now worked on almost 39
years it is the forest fragments project
north of an ass the city there is Manaus
there's a highway going straight north
and somewhere up to its right you'll
begin to see some clearings and maybe
some fragments within it but this will
give you a better view of that a little
bit later
NSF actually didn't think I could pull
this off
but they bought me an air ticket and
knowing Brazil having lived there for
two or three years I think helped a lot
within the first hour at the National
Institute for Amazon research I had
their agreement and later that afternoon
I had the agreement of the authority
that controlled the land then I had to
make it happen and that wasn't simple
but anyway so that's how it was all laid
out at the beginning and this had the
advantage that basically none of the
previous studies had that we could study
what would become fragments while they
were still part of continuous forest and
we could also have
matching plots in continuous forests so
that if we found something was changing
both in the fragments and in the
continuous forest we would know that
Canada is coming from something other
than habitat fragmentation and this is
it quite early on that's a ten hectare
fragment and I think that's a one and a
ten hectare fragment you can see all the
forest has been cut down it's about to
be burned they were turning it into
cattle pasture which doesn't make any
ecological or economic sense but there
were subsidies that made it economically
workable and there's one of the first
ten hectare fragments with a figure well
known at the time from wildlife ecology
named Raymond Desmond so I'm not going
to take you through a lot of graphs but
there was some really interesting things
that just popped up and surprised us to
begin with so this is the capture rate
of birds and mist nets in four different
fragments to be and then fragments and
there was this enormous increase after
fragmentation well what was happening
was there was actually a huge refugee
effect from the surrounding forest as it
was cut down and they went into the only
remaining forest but one of them
actually didn't show much of a refugee
effect and that's the exception that in
a sense mate proves the case because
it's this one where basically although
we had a hundred metres cleared around
it the birds that were in that hundred
metres when it came down had that much
bigger piece of forest to be absorbed by
so much less of a refugee effect and
then another big surprise you know the
number of butterfly species
declined initially and then recovered
and then kept increasing and actually
what was happening was the relatively
rare butterfly species that are part of
little tree fall gaps in the forest had
found these enormous tree list gaps
around the fragments and were just
exploding in population and then
invading the fragments so even though it
looked like the forest interior species
were increasing it wasn't the forest
interior species it was essentially the
exotics from tree fall gaps and another
result that we didn't anticipate was
just how vulnerable these fragments
would be to wind shear and storms and
the like and basically the smaller
fragments the one ones and tens lost up
to 35% of their biomass and never were
able to recover it and this will give
you a dramatic example this is the
center trail of a ten hectare reserve
after a big storm no longer a forest so
what about the birds in these forests so
what you can see is that the control
plots in continuous forests have more
bird species in them than the fragments
and that comes because they're isolated
and because they wink out and actually
what's going on in a simple kind of way
is just like a radioactive mineral loses
radio activity and declines to a simpler
state these forest communities are
losing species and declining to a
simpler state so this will give you
a really dramatic view of that about the
proportion extinct relative to the size
of the fragment but it took us more than
20 years to get this next result which
was sort of looking at something like a
half-life and basically what we found
was that birds of the forest interior
like this white ground ant bird which
are birds which do not go out into the
sunlight they will never go out of the
forest and in the sunlight darkness is
their cue half of the forest interior
bird species were lost from a hundred
hectare fragment in less than 15 years
so that's a pretty dramatic conclusion
but it took us about 20 years to get
there and then in the way the world
works
things changed and the subsidy which had
encouraged the cattle ranchers to try
and do miserable cattle ranching were
removed and basically the ranches were
largely abandoned and suddenly we were
facing second growth coming up around
our isolated fragments and it could get
pretty dramatic so this is what
twelve-year-old second-growth looks like
around one of these fragments we have
systematically we isolated our fragments
three times already
the last is about three years ago and
this is actually what it looks like for
110 hectare fragment a drone shot
essentially four years later it had all
been completely cut down right up to the
edge of the fragment four years before
and so we began to learn some other
things which were interesting that we
hadn't anticipated being able to learn
and one was that we actually had two
different kinds of vegetation accession
going on one the classic one of these
forests dominated by Cecropia but the
second dominated by the gene is called
vis mia which is quite toxic reproduces
by vegetative reproduction and comes up
almost in monoculture and you get very
different occupation of that second
growth by birds as a consequence so if
it's not burned it's just looking at
capture rate you get a lot more than if
it is burnt and you get larger number of
species so I think I made enough of a
case now that habitat fragmentation is a
serious conservation issue I'd like to
spend the remainder of this talk talking
about how can we start stitching back
all these fragments that we've created
in landscapes all around the world and
as I thought about it it's there almost
needs to be a science of connecting or
reconnecting and we have parts of it
there is a science of ecological
restoration
there's the interesting things that are
done by people here at Yale like David's
Kelly the little modifications that make
it easier for frogs to return to what
otherwise seemed perfectly fine water
bodies the kind of landscape planning
that's going on here but I think there
there is there is an overall science
that needs to be put together so that we
can start doing these connections
in a large scale so nobody has ever done
the experiment of taking two fragments
and reconnecting them with natural
vegetation and actually studying all the
bird species for example that take
advantage of that so I'm not going to
show you some examples where that was
done in terms of stitching it back
together but it was all about particular
rare bird species and improving their
overall amount of habitat and not
looking at the overall complex of change
that must go on when you do a
reconnection so these next slides are
courtesy of Stewart PIM has developed an
entire specialty of basically helping
the conservation of rare bird species by
literally doing this reconnecting one of
the places he's done it is in the
Atlantic forests of Brazil the red is
the greater number of threatened bird
species and that's the habitat which is
important for those bird species and you
can see he's identified a bunch of
potential linkages that might be
re-established and so that's it looking
at Google Earth and you're going to see
some of this actually getting done so
this is essentially the before hand in
2007 on the upper left and 2018
on the lower right where they've
actually managed to start some pretty
successful reforestation to connect to
remaining fragments that's it in 2007
and that's it as it's recovering
and there you have a good shot of it and
what do you do when you have a situation
like this with a major highway well
actually you can build an overpass and
that actually has been done and one of
the things I was delighted to learn
event six seven eight years ago
interstate highway funds can actually be
spent on building overpasses and
underpasses for wildlife I was thinking
you'd have to change the law but no it's
already in there it's even been done a
few times and here it's even being done
in Beijing and here's an interesting
example I ran into essentially a week or
two back it's looking at a very big
landscape in southern Africa basically
five countries with really important
features like the Okavango Delta
substantial percentages of remaining
cheetah and lions etc in southern Africa
and they're actually working with us
five sovereign governments World
Wildlife Fund to begin to essentially
guarantee the long-term connection of
those wildlife populations this is not
what they want to get to finally but
this is how far they're getting already
so that mean leads me to actually make
the point that one of our serious
problems in the world and one of the
things that creates a lot of fragments
is sort of the heedless way we build
infrastructure and this is a classic
pattern in the Brazilian Amazon where
one road starts and then it has little
side roads it's called the fishbone
pattern and all kinds of unanticipated
things happen as a consequence including
the use of fire so there is actually
already a strong effort not strong
enough to develop sustainable
infrastructure which may seem like an
oxymoron but I was at a meeting a year
or two ago with the Brazilian National
Development back there talking about
repaving or paving the last 300
kilometers of a road from Porto Velho to
Manaus which is a really bad idea
and I said well you know if you if you
really really really need that road why
don't you build an elevated road and
then an hour and a half later in the
program up pops this road in the
Atlantic forest of Brazil called
immigrant cheese its impact on the
ground is two-and-a-half percent of us
of a conventional highway it does cost
more to build for sure but if you
actually calculate in the maintenance
it's likely that the maintenance costs
on a standard highway would be really
high in the Wet Tropics and for
something that's built of concrete like
this quite low so it's probably
competitive and as you can see it does
wonders for natural connectivity so this
is another view of all of that
and then I want to just spend the
remaining time talking about natural
connections which naturally occur if not
interfered with in the landscape namely
riparian vegetation the vegetation that
grows along water courses and I've got a
lot of pretty pictures of that but I
first got my attention paid to that when
I was Bruce Babbitt science advisor and
they were working on the northwest
forest plan and he sent me at to see how
was going and they were deciding at that
time just how wide the band would be
along water courses to be essentially no
touch to create the kind of habitat that
salmon love they just loved all kinds of
dead trees and stuff that have fallen
into the stream and and so I looked at
it I saw this incredible amount of
connection that would put back into the
landscape and so I became really
interested in riparian vegetation as one
way to do that and in particular I
became really sort of fascinated with
the way very often a landowner
will graze cattle right up to the edge
of the water course or plow right up to
the edge of the water course wanting to
maximize every square meter of land they
have but of course what's happening is
they're losing their soil by the cubic
meter
it really did an economic analysis they
wouldn't want to do that and
interestingly enough I went to Peoria
Illinois for a caterpillar corporation
sustainability meeting and that time
what
taxi driver was a local farmer through a
generation making a little extra change
and they just volunteered you know that
everybody out there was doing no-till
and I thought well that's really
interesting central Illinois no chill
and on the same trip I learned that
there had been so much soil erosion over
time that the local government had found
its it worth its while to spend more
millions of dollars and I can remember
anymore to actually dredge it back out
of the river and sell it back to the
farmers so I think riparian vegetation
is well worth having a major global
campaign for and we'll just see some
really nice examples I've heard a sea of
the National Geographic
so these are some of the things that I
think habitat fragmentation and
developing an agenda for reducing the
amount of fragmentation in the natural
world can involve and it's it's it's
just beginning I think we haven't done a
lot of the science yet sometimes it can
be a mistake to do I remember a proposal
to reconnect to wild areas and and
Southern Africa that looked like it
would actually introduce rinderpest to a
region where it had been eliminated so
there's a lot to learn about it but I
think as we look forward to how we can
actually have human aspiration better
embedded in nature stitching the pieces
back together and celebrating riparian
vegetation is part of the way to go
thank you very much
[Applause]
please identify yourself first and my
favorite client yes yeah that doesn't
need to be on please disguise your
comment as a question so that other you
can also ask questions so the floor is
open
indeed scientific experiment being
ruined by the regrowing forest and i
wonder if you would just talk a little
bit about what it's like to do manage to
work in a foreign country doing an
experiment that is so big where you have
to do things like isolate your habitat
if you want to study it and keep it from
regrowing so it's always an adventure
right but basically I think we've been
able to actually manage the regrowth
problem enough that the basic experiment
goes ahead but there's really
interesting information in terms of the
things that will actually use that
second growth while it's there and then
you know you go back and reset by doing
the the isolation so it's not always
been easy in terms of trying to do a
project in the middle of the Amazon in
Brazil Brazil is not got a great
reputation for welcoming crowds of
foreign researchers but it helped
amongst other things that you know I
spoke Portuguese everybody can tell I
love Brazil when I'm there I mean how
can you're not and and because it was
science it was much easier to do than
just jumping into something that might
be closer to policy and one of the
things it was absolutely fascinating
about it is that even before we had any
results because we were asking this
question
all the protected areas being created in
the Brazilian Amazon were large and it's
like we could be drinking beer out in
the forest and still affecting public
policy and they had a very wise first
secretary of the Environment named Paulo
Nogueira Netta
who was in office for I think something
like 12 years he presided over the
creation of some of the best
environmental law in Latin America
during his time period he protected huge
areas which he was able to get set aside
and Paulo almost became like a father
figure to me and he's still alive right
and you know we would I would always
talk to him on Christmas Eve which is
their holiday and mmm not more than a
minute or two would go by then he would
want to talk about environment and
science and so one of the wonderful
things he did a year before or months
before leaving office he said you know
give me all the coordinates of your
reserves which I did and he turned them
into a presidential decree so this is
part of the Brazilian protected area
system now I've had some hard times
there was some wacko person who accused
me of being a bio it bio pirate right
and I used to joke about I was gonna get
a green Pirates hat and it actually led
to a parliamentary inquiry which of
course found nothing but you know always
you know you have to have friends and
lots of places so
yeah including in the Brazilian media
and I mean like like today I was telling
the students at lunch I had an article
appear in the folio snell Paulo
which is the largest circulation
newspaper in Brazil about I think it's
time we modernized the infrastructure
plants for the Amazon because they're
really all 50 years old and you have to
think about what you're trying to
achieve and then think about ways to
design it that has much less impact
ah hi I'm John we're met here in the
School of Forestry Bible studies and
Yale Divinity School with a joint degree
program on religion and ecology and I
wanted to draw you out when you
initiated the fragment the study of
fragments in the
10:41 is located as I recall what kind
of conversations did you have with the
ranchers and farmers a really good
question well I mean you know it was it
it was that's a really really
interesting question and it helped that
in fact we weren't taking anything away
from anybody they had to leave 50
percent in forests and we actually did
them enormous favors by getting in there
and studying sort of the lay of the land
which they had no idea about so we could
tell them where the streams were and
where the the flat places were and so
they got some benefits from that as well
and and it's something that is very
Brazilian they liked the idea that they
were part of something that was getting
a lot of attention so none of those
original owners are there anymore and I
actually worry about the long-term
security of those plots so I'm trying to
look for a way to turn it into a much
larger protected area and play into the
interests of the the governor of that
state and developing a serious
ecotourism agency or business so anyway
gene
thank you Tom that was wonderful
Jean Thompson Blackie Oh University
Press invasive species I love the
example of the riparian habitats but
systems I'm most familiar would say out
west where their issues with Russia well
it's it's a real issue and some are more
invasive than others some are easier to
sort of actually sort of keep under some
kind of moderate control without a lot
of work and then uh others aren't so in
in the Amazon there hardly any invasive
species haven't actually been able to
get there it's certainly probably
different in the Atlantic forest region
of Brazil and there's there's just
endless amounts of bracken fern which is
an invasive hive but at least up in the
North it's not such a serious issue
yeah there you have to wait for a
microphone
thank you working so the question for
the past four years I was working for
the San Paulo state secretary of
environment and a discussion that I was
we would get a lot is creating
additional protected areas to connect
fragments that we have in the San Paulo
state which are a lot and one of the
main criticism that we would hear is
that instead of creating extra protected
areas and parts it will be better to
focus on our efforts and our resource on
taking care of the areas that we already
have so I would love to hear your
opinion on that like relationship
between like spending resources and
effort on areas that are already created
and not getting a lot of attention
versus like creating extra choice so so
my attitude of that kind of a question
is that's actually a budget issue right
and if you can increase the budget then
you don't have to make those kinds of
unnecessary trade-offs that might not
actually get you very far in a
particular place and you know I'm
acutely aware that a lot of the
protected areas in the Brazilian Amazon
are actually almost you know with only
one or two people looking after them
they're their classic paper parks you
know I don't worry about them right now
because they're just so isolated there's
no immediate threats but that's not
always going to be the case and that's
why they've been major programs like the
Amazon region protected area one and two
created to help with all of that so my
first instinct without knowing any of
the details is sort of binary choice
is that some of those fragments actually
might be more important to spend money
on at least in the short term to get
them secured one way or another and yes
if you have a protected area of State
Park somewhere that's having a serious
invasion problem not from invasive
species but from people well then maybe
you do actually need to do something
there and his sound Pamela state is such
an interesting state because they
decided I don't know when this was 40
years ago that they wanted to have
something like the National Science
Foundation
it's called footpaths P it's a classic
Brazilian acronym and it doesn't have to
go for an appropriation every year it by
the state constitution gets one percent
of the state revenue and Ashley in the
first years after setting that up they
didn't pass any of the revenue on and
then some governor discovered that and
so there was a lot of back long that was
all given to focus via wants it so they
have an endowment as well as this one
percent well the consequence is that you
get really high quality sustained
science and science projects supported
by 5sp and you know maybe we need to
look for something like that for
protection of protected areas
dr. Lovejoy thank you for a great
presentation
my name is Helen hid my McClaskey fellow
whose cocaine yield for about two months
I had the fortune of working in one of
the landscapes that you presented the
Casa villa the Casa Roland and also to
put together some of the habitat
corridors that I used to buy by
elephants in that area but my question
has to do with the forest often it's
obviously the fragments fragmentation as
you showed in your earlier slides is
significant if far along that fragments
that the restoration doesn't occur
naturally
the stitching back does not occur
naturally and I'm wondering whether you
had occasion to work in forests where
people have had to help stitch back the
forest fragments so that you could
actually create those big connections
and how different that may be it's a
really good question that you know I've
been asked many times why we didn't
include some stitching back experiments
and what we were doing and the answer is
very simple we had so much to do just
looking at learning about fragmentation
firsthand that it would have it would
have been beyond our ability to add
anything more but there there are many
wonderful things that have come from
this project other than answering some
of these questions and producing some of
the science and that as we produce close
to 200 PhDs and master's degrees and at
least half of those are Brazilian and as
I said I wanted a you know and they grow
up and they get grown-up jobs so one of
them was actually head of conservation
for the entire state of Amazonas which
is the largest political unit in South
America other than a
country its 2.3 times the size of Texas
and the one place in the Amazon where a
highway has not led to massive
deforestation is in southern Amazonas
where Rita who you that burritos set up
a whole bunch of protected areas and
it's not that there isn't some tension
and problem they are in need for
enforcement and the life but it actually
has been working thank you so much Tom
wonderful talk Mary Lynn Tucker forestry
and environmental studies in the Yale
Divinity School you've spent a good part
of your career navigating between
science and policy and as president of
conservation biology you did a wonderful
editorial on how science has got to come
into the space of policy and even dare I
say advocacy it seems as though over
your career science has come a long way
and you've been instrumental in that
towards science for solutions but
there's still obstacles to that
objectivity distance empirical studies
versus actually saying what is needed I
just wonder if you can comment on this
science policy dance so you know oh and
the other question yeah I'm just a
writer on that you know the science is
really good at sort of figuring out what
we might want to do it sounds like you
have a lot of experience working with
local municipalities and state
governments so I was wondering if you
could share some advice or what some of
your successes have been based on and
getting people on board with the why we
should care about these things well you
know there was one big plus working in
favor of all of this is that
the Brazilian ministries have tended to
be very technocratic and they really
want to know the science so so that
helps and I just never seen any problem
between you know saying this is the
science this is what we've discovered
this is what it means like we did just
now and then you know saying I think
this is the way we need to start talking
about what this might mean for changing
the way we might do things for the
better
and it's it's always a lot of listening
got to do a lot of listening right
[Applause]
[Music]